people will hate you for who you are
more so because of what it makes them
feel about themselves the strategy of
what i do is
make stuff that is really valuable to
people from in the trenches experience
that is happening in real time right now
that they can use and make money with
you will attract much better talent
having a better opportunity vehicle
overall the best people are attracted to
the best opportunities we're big fans of
imperfect action you learn through doing
not through preparing to do because i
think a lot of times you learn as you're
doing what things you thought were
important at the onset are significantly
less important so it's like you know i
think the thumbnails and the headlines
and the first you know 20 seconds matter
a lot more than spending an hour setting
up the lighting
there he is
what's up evan how's it going alex from
was in the house how you doing man
good i'm in my my closet my uh you know
my my world's greatest closet the
youtube studio
i love a lot of stuff about you but but
the first one was dude this guy just
gets up and he's proof that great
content wins
because you're sitting in the closet and
without with like total respect but it's
not about like a high-end camera and
editing and b-roll it's like here's a
guy
sits in his closet and just speaks his
truth into the camera and i think that's
what holds a lot of people back man it's
like they're too afraid to to get going
because they don't have the perfect gear
and perfect microphone and here's alex
with his nose strip and undershirt in
his closet just making videos
you know as a side note um
a big part so there's a handful of key
things that made me decide to start like
making content and things like that was
about i guess now 18 months ago because
before that i was kind of silent on
social media by and large and it was
actually an interview that you had done
with bradley
um where you said there's this huge
vacuum on youtube um with regards to
like i think you said like higher level
business stuff from people who were
business people but not youtube
influencers who were who made their
money you know doing youtube stuff but
made their money elsewhere and could
apply those principles and i think you
had said something to the extent of like
it doesn't need to be dolled up
you know it's just it's basically what
you're saying we're like at the end of
the day if the content is is good enough
or valuable enough to the audience
people
there's a there's a big audience for it
that's that's not being served and so
that was actually one of the the two or
three things that that pushed me over
the edge to start making content um so i
i want to i'll thank you for that uh
because that was one of the podcasts
that um that really made me take a big
step towards deciding to do it cool man
well i'm glad that helped it's a small
world and listen a lot of a lot of
people then who look like you who've
done who've had a lot of success in the
business world then come to make youtube
content
they're off building seven-figure
studios like i've helped a lot of these
guys get their channels launched and
they won't do it until it's perfect and
they have a seven figure like home
studio spending six figures just on this
one arm to move a camera around like
legit and then and they're too afraid to
get started because they've hit success
in one field and now they're coming to
something new
and they don't want to get started
looking bad from scratch
you on the other hand not that you look
back but it's like it's it's you like
this this is alex is going to show up
he's going to share his wisdom and and
so how did you did you just never care
or how did you get over that hurdles
like you know what i'm just gonna make
it
i mean we're big fans of imperfect
action and so and i think that we're
also at least i'm a big student of like
you learn through doing not through
preparing to do because i think a lot of
times you learn as you're doing what
things you thought were important at the
onset are significantly less important
so it's like you know i think the
thumbnails and the headlines and the
first you know 20 seconds matter a lot
more than spending an hour setting up
the lighting you know what i mean and so
it's just like return on time and effort
um and so yeah so i mean if we want to
learn something new at least in the
companies that we have it's like we just
start doing we pull we pull the thread
that we can see we just keep pulling and
figure it out as we go and i think we
end up getting to where we're trying to
go faster
just through ex giving ourselves
permission to suck
i love it now i've helped a lot of
people kind of move from direct
marketing world into youtube land and
almost immediately it's okay how do i
get them in my free ebook and click and
you know funnel them and and retarget
them and sell my coaching and upload all
this because it's like that's just part
of ingrained mindset of direct marketing
yeah i know was waiting for the shoe to
drop with alex okay where's alex's thing
and just video to video it's not there
why isn't it there because in your gym
business you did it all yourself and
then you you you taught
the trainings like i don't want to do
this i mean i'll teach you how to do it
why why did this not become i'll teach
you how to do this too
i think i think my view of business has
shifted over time and so i think that if
you have a longer time horizon and you
have capital or you don't need the money
from whatever you know promotion you're
doing i think
that goodwill compounds faster than
revenue uh and so
i think what you said is a really
perfect example of like i think a lot of
people are always waiting for the other
shoe to drop when people are receiving
value and so right at that point
whenever they're expecting that shoe to
drop and then it doesn't they do make a
purchase but they make a purchase of
goodwill which is all of a sudden they
transition from i really like this guy's
stuff let's see what he sells me to i
really like this stuff i'm gonna tell
other people because he hasn't tried to
sell anything and so i think that's
where you get like an additional
component of virality two stuff and i
think it depends on the mission of the
person you know what i mean like this is
not how i make my money um at all uh and
so
you know and a lot of this stems from
a rather contrarian worldview that i
have which is just like i don't think
many of the things that we do will
amount to anything in the long term and
so the things that i enjoy that i do
meaningful
are helping you know other entrepreneurs
get started because i know that i was in
a very dark place when i started and if
you know if the lessons that i had that
caused me pain
can help someone else then they won't
have been in vain overall and so that's
that's kind of the the catalyst behind
doing all the stuff um to begin with but
the reason i don't sell stuff is
partially for goodwill partially because
i don't want to create a business around
this um now we do i mean obviously we
have our our portfolio so you know if if
if somebody has a company that's doing
three million five million ten million
twenty million um you know forty million
a year and they want uh want help and
they you know they found valuable stuff
then yeah we're we'd love to but we're
buying not selling uh it's
a slightly different uh conversation but
that's that's it's a different way of of
doing it and an old business model to be
honest like warren buffett and charlie
munger you know having in the private
equity world too it's like creating what
they call propriety flow um is a very
valuable thing and so
uh i think naval ravicon also said one
of the best ways to monetize a brand is
to
uh monetize off like the point zero zero
zero one percent like if you just got
shares in facebook early on you could do
everything else you want in life for
free and help everybody uh rather than
trying to sell something to everyone and
they're just different strategies
overall it's just for me i also prefer
and feel like i can provide the most
value to a business that's very big and
growing um and to everyone else it's
like i can help more people without
introducing operational complexity or
loss of goodwill um by just providing
this stuff for free
so you go from in your late teens and
early 20s kind of living your dad's life
going to school being a management
consultant the whole kind of iranian
work ethic become a doctor
all that stuff and then at 22 you decide
no uh
peace out i'm not doing this and and
your dad feels you're making this giant
mistake
um but then but then what i loved about
that story was that he comes back and
gives you his his only ever apology to
you
uh for saying it was a mistake
what did you what did you have to do to
then ultimately make him proud that he
apologized to you
well
i mean there's probably there's probably
layers to this you know i mean
everyone's relationship with their
parents are different but for me at
least my my dad he he was very much a
material success guy um like every time
he introduced somebody like before he
got in the car after he got the party
they go this is so so this is how much
money he makes right and so it was very
clear whether he said it consciously or
unconsciously like that money was what
to him is what was most respectable
about someone um he would probably not
like me saying that but not through his
words but through his actions it became
clear to me that that is what he valued
and so for me to gain
the affirmation or the approval of my
father
i had to make money but he also has his
you know his own ego and his own pride
and whatnot and so it couldn't be like i
just have to match the amount of money
that he makes it's like i had to make
more money than it ever made in his
entire life um for that to really
solidify and we're both pretty um
domineering personalities and so we had
to there was like a five-year period
where we didn't talk too much um
and there i think there had to be a
power shift um that had to occur and it
only really occurred when uh the
the evidence was overwhelming um and so
like when i started making money um i
mean i think the first year that we made
like 10 million dollars uh
he was like well we'll see how long it
lasts like it wasn't you know what i
mean so like it it wasn't just like you
have to make more money it was it was it
had to be so insurmountable the evidence
that it was undeniable and so i think
that that's also been a theme that that
i applied to a lot of the facets of my
life is that just through my own
insecurities um i wanted to
create uh
you know different different pillars of
my life that would be successful quote
like beyond reproach so that no one can
say like alex is in good shape he's like
no he's in such crazy shape that no one
can say that he's overweight right or
you know he's he's he's not just like
doing okay but he's making so much money
that no one can say that he's not
successful i think honestly that's just
because of my own insecurities i don't
think that's a
testament to anything besides that um i
may still harbor those and i just have
evidence that that allows me to function
you know better
you know and live a live a more normal
lifestyle rather than
continually suffer from those just
because those that evidence acts as a
crutch against the insecurities that i
have so hopefully that makes some sense
i love it so i've got a fun exercise
that i wanted as soon as as soon as i
found that you're coming on like okay
here's here's what i want to ask alex
talking about growth and most people
watching in my honest your answer
probably in the early stage still into
like i'm even just trying to get i'm
getting started to get started but
you've also focused on a lot of the
high-end strategies as well as what you
can do to actually grow so i'm wondering
from
your first 10 000 to then like and not
just you like maybe prescriptive advice
now and then let's have a zero each time
so 10 000 to 100 000 a million like
what's the mindset shift that i have to
go
by adding a zero to my revenue
every step of the way so i don't get
stuck
it's it's a really good question so when
you're adding zeros you're you're you're
adding an order of magnitude right so
it's a multiple you know 10 that's
happening with each of those scenarios
and the only way you can really just add
an order of magnitude is not by doing 10
times more work but by adding leverage
right and so we have to have leverage to
the things that we do and so you know in
the beginning you transition from being
employed to being self-employed right
and so that's like kind of the first
transition and then your your limit is
going to be your time and how much you
can build per hour right
from there your your next level is going
to be building the core team which is
usually five you know five or so people
which will be representative of
departmental functions within a company
right you'll have some element of
promotion some element of selling some
element of customer service some element
of finance and
things like like and that would probably
and then you are kind of managing in
that you're not really really leading
yet you're really just managing the
people below you and in that in that
time typically you are better at the job
at each of those roles than the people
beneath you because you cannot afford
people who will be better than you at
those roles
from there adding another level of
leverage you then add another layer of
management that goes and then you really
transition into being a leader because
you can't
possibly like each of those people now
have five people underneath of them
right now you're now you're at
you know 25 or 30 people and most of the
um
most of these stagnation points do
happen uh around triplings um and that's
usually because another whole layer of
infrastructure needs to get built within
a company um and so that's where people
don't know what has to happen and so
that's when you go you know and what's
your leader you have to go into like
kind of step into the visionary role and
you're really hiring people who come
with batteries included solutions
already having proven inside of them not
i have to go find some person teach them
how to manage a sales team teach them
how to recruit like no like you're
finding somebody's already built a 30
person sales team to help you build take
your take your five person to a 30
person sales team right it's like you
want to find somebody's already run the
olympic gold and then have them run it
with you rather than like oh i'm a
running coach i've never run gold but
i'll try and do it with you and the
thing is is that when you're earlier on
the reason it's difficult is because you
can't afford some of those people yet
and so that's why early on you have to
spend a disproportionate amount of time
learning the skills right rather than um
rather than hiring people who already
have those skills so in the beginning
you're learning and your ability to
learn is the bottleneck and later it's
your ability to recruit people who have
learned and so it's just like in
business where you can buy or you can
build like in terms of growing through
mergers and acquisitions so this is
really going from top down
at a at a medium level you can buy or
build talent you can buy talent by
paying premium dollars for the best
people or you can build it and both of
those are strategies you can build a a
system for for design for designing and
training sales people that was something
that we were really good at and so we
could take people for less than top
dollar and then make them into top
dollar sales people right now the the
risk that you have there is that some
people then start recruiting your sales
people right because you because you did
the building for them but it just
depends on the strategy of the business
in terms of you know overall and so um
in terms of going from 10k to a a month
to a million a month to 10 million a
month each of those represent orders of
magnitude um on leverage that you can
employ within the business and i'll just
finish with one little thing i know just
ran it a little bit um
but the the leverage and this is from
naval robocop this isn't me but i
remember the four c's he doesn't say
four c's i remember four students
because otherwise i can't remember it
but it's like you've got you've got code
you've got content you've got
collaboration you've got capital right
and so collaboration is the base of that
pyramid just getting other people to do
stuff for you so you get time back by
having other people give you their time
and you pay them for it right the level
above that is capital you use other
people's money to fuel growth right and
if you know how to structure your
business properly you can also use your
customers money to fuel growth if you
prop if you if you monetize well in that
you can if you can set up your your
marketing in your sales system such that
you can make more money than it costs to
acquire customer and the next customer
within the first 30 days you have a
negative acquisition cost which means
you can use that money to then go get
more customers you basically have a
limitless acquisition cycle now you'll
still have bottlenecks but there'll be
infrastructure bottlenecks on the back
end so there's always a bottleneck but
it no longer becomes acquisition so you
have collaboration then you have capital
and then the top two are are content and
code so you have software which has zero
cost of replication which gives you
limitless leverage and to the same
degree like what you've done uh with
media right content uh it doesn't cost
more money for more people to see this
like if you and i were on here with just
one person or you and i are here with a
million people it costs the same amount
for us to do it but we have leverage and
so with most businesses and this is like
a fun rule of thumb for anybody who's
looking
when you look at the biggest businesses
that have been around the longest they
typically will have all four of those
aspects
of leverage built within the business
like you look at facebook they have they
have lots of people they have capital
from the outside they sell media based
on code right um and so as you're
looking to scale the company it's like
how many boxes of these leverage can i
check and i would even look at my own
life and i'd say right now we have three
of the four like i don't have a big
software component within my business
but we do have media we do have uh
collaboration and we do have capital and
so i think that for us and i made a
presentation about this like i think for
us going from 10 million a month to
maybe 100 a month i'll probably have to
figure out some sort of code thing uh
but you know at current uh we're able to
you know still do 10 million a month
with the stuff that we're doing
and i know you've gone off on software
companies unless you're absolutely
dedicated to running the software
company you've made some videos talking
to you basically
get your championship to the draft right
it's like you're picking the right
person right and you're picking them on
the draft and leela's got the gut
instinct and she's the best at doing it
but
in free agency so the draft is you're
picking somebody out of college and
they're young and hungry again but
they're already good and you're making
them better versus free agency you're
getting already the best they may not be
with you for too long like you think
that the yankees just constantly buying
the best players but maybe not having
the best farm system
interesting so it's so the question is
buying or building kind of what we were
referencing earlier like would i prefer
to buy buy the talent or build the
talent in the building you're already
still going for
the upper echelon right like you're
recruiting out of harvard instead of
just recruiting anybody it's one on the
pick and i think one of those is like
it gets more nuanced but like you can
see raw potential
uh and say like okay
like the people coming out of harvard
have raw potential they usually don't
have a tremendous amount of experience
right and so you're still just taking
somebody who's at a higher echelon of
processing power work ethic because they
had to to get to that point so they've
proven all these base characteristics
and then then we can equip them with
kind of the more niche skills um but i
think it's probably a combination of
both and if layla were here should give
you probably a sexier answer um i think
that what she would normally say because
this is definitely her her realm is the
80 20 split is that you want 20 of the
people that are on your team to already
have been there done that and then the
80
to be kind of building their their
arsenal skill set and that also balances
usually where the compensation goes you
know i mean because you're paying for
the road map with the people who are in
the 20
and then the 80 are learning from the 20
and then in their next chapter they
might be in the 20 because they did it
with you and your company um i think the
goal is always to keep people you know
as long as we can provide meaningful
opportunity to them and i think to to go
back to the original leverage thing you
will attract much better talent having a
better opportunity vehicle overall so
people will be the best people are
attracted to the best opportunities and
so if you want to start a dry cleaning
business in a brick-and-mortar business
you probably won't get you know a
harvard business school graduate this is
probably not going to be you probably
can't pay them
it's probably just not overwhelmingly
interesting to them right and so is
there a way that we can transform that
well probably you know if you if all of
a sudden you worked with a thousand dry
cleaners because you had a licensing
system or a franchise model then you
might be able to attract that person
because the opportunity superior and so
i think um
it is one in the draft but part of
winning in the draft is having is being
the yankees
and you can get talent for less if
you're the patriots because they want to
be on a championship team right and so
it's kind of the it goes back and forth
on both sides like you can pick better
people which create championship teams
but championship teams attract better
people i love it listen everybody's
commenting about your nose strip what
when do we get when do we get the mosey
nation
nation sponsors yeah that that's that's
the product to sell yeah right yeah that
and beaters you know my wife my
proprietary white peter uh you know i
will say this i've had a lot of people
do i mean like dude if you release no
strip like it's not my business you know
what i mean and so i think a lot of
people they're they they are so what
happens is they are so afraid of leaving
money on the table they leave the
biggest money on the table because
they're trying to you don't want to
sacrifice an empire to pick up a pot of
gold right and so
we risk our empire we risk the big thing
the main thing by getting distracted
because it's not poor to the strategy
right like the strategy of what i do is
make stuff that is really valuable to
people from in the trenches experience
that is happening in real time right now
that they can use and make money with
and if they then use it and make money
and never work with me i sleep fine if
they do end up becoming you know they
cross the three million five million ten
million dollar threshold and then they
want to work with us because they know
the stuff that we did worked awesome and
then we're buying and not selling right
in the same situation and that's the
strategy now if so you don't even be
like what am i really gonna make with a
with uh with a no strip right like let's
say even you know ten thousand people
buy no strips for what twenty bucks you
know i mean like 200 grand 200 a month
it's not worth the brand equity you know
what i mean it's the short cash grab
that just doesn't make sense at least
for me for the big picture of where
we're trying to go so that's why we
don't pick up that stuff i'd even give
it away for free like it's just branding
yeah yeah no no that would work too you
know and honestly like i think it i
think what you represent
is
is even bigger than the message in that
here's a guy who's just willing to show
up as he is like who else is on most
guys who look like you who've done what
you've done would be super like i has to
be i got my suit on i need to have it
perfect and you're in an undershirt in
the nose trips and it just it represents
the the willingness to just be
unapologetically you
because most people are still living
under their father's thumb and saying no
i'm going to go stick being a mainstream
consultant because i'm afraid to be me
like that's what a nostril represents to
me is like the courage to go off and be
you and not hide
no i appreciate it and one of the things
that layla said one of her biggest fears
was you know because we had to
consciously say like do we want
to gain fame you know i mean because
like we think if we're going to do it
we're going to try and do our best and
we think people you know it'll gain
notoriety i think the last you know 12
to 18 months have been has been proof of
that but like you give up some stuff
like you give up the ability to walk out
and not have people recognize you and
things like that and one of the things
that she said she was afraid of um she's
like i never want someone to meet me and
be like you're so different in person
you know what i mean and so
i think a lot of that is is
you brought up the you know the word you
know unapologetically yourself you know
we like to define authenticity in terms
of like what you truly believe deep down
is aligned with what you actually say
and what you say is aligned with what
you actually do and if all three of
those things are aligned then you
are in alignment and i think people can
feel that um and i think a lot like
a lot of people are really afraid to
tell people what they really think um
and then they're definitely afraid to
act in accordance with that and so i
think um
yeah i mean i think i guess it's it's
courage to be hated because you can't
people will hate you for who you are
more so because of what it makes them
feel about themselves and so but that's
but like being able to separate that
heap from
uh
how i quantify my own self-worth or how
much i respect myself um
is something that you have to separate i
think at some point i know there's a
little bit of a tangent there but it's
just you know top of mind that's great i
mean you're i think what's fun with you
is your equal part like pragmatist and
strategies and philosopher
[Laughter]
this is a beautiful little mix um as
someone me who struggled with uh fame
and ego when they didn't want to be
about me and just hide behind the people
i was profiling i fought with my agent
for years on this and uh
he eventually worked it in that hey the
more people know you the more people
will hear the message and will then take
action that like your story actually has
a ton of power and
one of the greatest compliments i got of
all time was an event i was doing and
the guy came up to me in minnesota
afterwards and said hey you're even
better in person than
what i thought right and so it's like it
doesn't have to go the other way in
terms of leila's fears that you're
totally different it could be even
better in person if that's how you
decide to show up yeah and that's
hopefully the hopefully the goal right
and shout out to leila two she's got her
own youtube channel we'll link that up
in the description of this youtube video
after too um let's just close up on on
framework so you have
so many frameworks
for decision making or algorithms like
internal aleks algorithms what are some
of the most important frameworks for you
that allow you to make decisions a lot
faster
well they kind of get generated on
demand you know i mean it depends on the
problem that we're trying to solve and
so it's like if we're trying to grow
business then they're gonna be certain
frameworks we're gonna look at it
through if it's if it's a framework
around like how do i feel about about a
certain situation like there's a
stimulus there's a circumstance that
arises like how am i going to react you
know you have your frameworks around
that there's frameworks that use in
marriage right and so i think it would
depend on the frameworks that you use in
how you train you're like your body how
do i eat how do i sleep how to like all
of those are different frameworks and i
think for the big picture a lot of
people like frameworks are just are just
shortcuts for decision making and so
what we're doing is just codifying the
variables that we use to make a decision
uh deliberately so that the next time
we're confronted with the decision we
don't need to you remake and re-walk
through that process so that we can save
the time and energy and so you know if
you're confronted with thousands of
decisions every day
if you have to remake all of these
decisions over and over again you waste
a tremendous amount of time and
attention whereas if you can
once you like once you've made the
decision once it's made forever because
you have the process documented then you
just are able to have a lot more
leverage on your time and then make a
higher
number of decisions and quality of
decisions because quantity based on the
fact that you're using a framework
that's shorthand for good decision
making and then the quality based on the
fact that you have so much excess
attention now from what you gained back
on these prior decisions that you don't
have to remake uh to then apply them to
the ones that are more complex that are
more strategic that have higher leverage
and will your yield outside returns in
your business your life your marriage
your your body whatever
i know legacy doesn't matter you and and
i don't focus on it either and and i'm
also curious to know if you know any of
your like 800 cousin or homo or mozy
cousins from from around iran in the
world um i'm wondering what keeps you on
on the good side because a lot of people
they stay they stay good because of
legacy or because of faith or god or
whatever you have so many skills that
could very easily be turned to the
negative you're getting sales and
persuasions and easily ripping people
off if you wanted to when you have all
those skill sets to do it and make
short-term arbitrage and screw people if
you wanted to right what keeps you on
the good side
of life if it's not faith and it's not
legacy
it's a really this is a really
interesting question we'll probably go
over uh i'll say
um
but i think that um i i would i would
write a gut instinct i would initially
reject the good versus bad um and i
think that it's just a difference in
time horizon and so
i would make the argument that i am
better at being selfish than the person
who is short-sighted
so they are also being selfish i am
being selfish i'm just being selfish
long they're being selfish short and so
um it's like if you have the patience uh
to just wait for a long period of time
and i think i've made some content on
this which is like you can just give
give give and you never need to ask and
at a certain point you just start
getting right um
and so you know it would be like akin to
me trying to
you know in the very beginning i had no
followers no nothing and being like hey
evan like let's hop on a thing together
you might be like i don't know man but
if you build enough on your own then
then someone reaches out right and so um
i don't think it's good or evil uh i
think it's just long versus short and so
i would say that that's really the issue
and as a quick
uh tie into what you would you mentioned
earlier about direct response uh
marketers i think the difference is
between direct response and branding and
in my opinion branding has a
significantly higher return on
advertising spend and effort
um
if measured over a longer time horizon
direct response has a much higher roads
you know return on return on spend on a
short time rising and so if you can wait
for the longer time ryzen 2 compound
then you're like louis vuitton just has
a picture of a model next to a purse
they don't need to say two bags for you
know two bags fifty percent off they
don't need to do two upsells immediately
after that because they know that they
can sell a bag for five thousand dollars
that cost them a hundred dollars to make
right because of the brand but you don't
get that overnight you get that over
years and over decades and if you want
that kind of power it takes time and so
it's still very selfish to do it that
way you're just patient
he's a philosopher i love it
listen final final question for people
who who you give so much
to everybody now and and as you famous
just say you got nothing to sell you're
just here trying to try to help and
serve when your book is 99 cents but if
people wanted to like out of that you've
given so much importance to them if they
were going to think about you today
and whether it's just holding you in
their thoughts or taking some kind of
action in their life like what would you
have them do if they want to repay you
somehow through their thoughts or
actions
i mean share it share the stuff help
other people out um i mean somebody was
like what can i do for you like be
successful like that's like just don't
be you know don't be in your in your
parents basement not doing something
like that's what you can do because for
me like you said i know i'm gonna die
and people will forget about me in 500
years doesn't matter right and so um
like do something for you and that that
makes me happy um and you know from a
monetary perspective if you crush it you
cross 3 million 10 million whatever and
you want us to like participate and and
help you go further we'd love to invest
we love to talk that's what
acquisition.com is about so like that's
you know that's our play but for
everybody else we're just here to help
and you know if you just go from ten
thousand a month to a hundred thousand a
month and you never get past that
i love you you know what i mean like you
did it you took action you you're
already probably in the one percent of
americans and you need to be recognized
for that recognize yourself um and
that's that's that's all i mean that's
that's it what else is there you know i
mean like i think um this might be a
good statement to close with but like um
leon
shoot l.l bean leon i think his last
name is leon wood uh who started l.l
bean uh when asked why he didn't make
ella bean more profitable or more
aggressively you know do stuff he says i
already three meals a day he's like what
would i do with a fourth right and i
think that that's that's um
a lot of the perspective with it which
is like a lot of people want to start
businesses because they want to work
with people they care about to do
something they find meaningful to help
people and it's like well then i mean
that's that's what we do and so
we're like you're helping people what do
you want back like that's what people
say they want to do to begin with so
it's like well that's i'm i'm doing the
thing i don't you know i'm doing the
thing
leon leon would be that was a really
obscure reference but i love it
alex hemos in the house appreciate your
man thank you for the love the energy of
the time all the content you're making
for showing up and dude i'm super
excited to see
everything else you're gonna be making
especially the content i really love
what you're putting out in the world and
i really appreciate you
appreciate you thank you for taking the
time and your audience you know very
nice to meet you thank you for giving us
your attention um and hopefully you got
a good return on it thank you man take
care we'll see you soon if you want to
see my recent one-on-one with grant
cardone check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there true
wealth cannot be created working it can
only be created investing elon musk is
completely invested
he has no cash and no houses